>> Laura: IT'S TIME FOR ARSENE
AND UNSEEN SEGMENT.
WE EXPOSE THE CULTURAL STORIES
OF THE DAY IN TURN TO RAYMOND
ARROYO.
RAYMOND, PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
ADDRESSED CONGRESS TODAY
VIRTUALLY.
>> HE USED THE ADDRESS TO ASK
FOR PLANES, A NO-FLY ZONE, USED
HEART-WRENCHING VIDEO TO MAKE
HIS CASE, THAN HE ADDRESSED
PRESIDENT BIDEN DIRECTLY.
LISTEN.
>> YOUR BEING ASKED TO BE THE
LEADER OF THE WORLD, BEING THE
LEADER OF THE WORLD MEANS TO BE
THE LEADER OF PIECE.
STRONG, BRAVE AND READY TO WRIT
FOR THE LIVES OF HIS CITIZENS
AND THE CITIZENS OF THE WORLD.
>> THAT IS A CURIOUS THING THERE
.
HE IS FADING THIS THUG HOOTON,
HE KILLS PEOPLE IN HIS OWN
COUNTRY, HE'S A MONSTER, BUT HE
SAYING HERE THAT SOMEHOW, BIDEN
HAS TO BE A LEADER OF THE WORLD
A CITIZEN OF THE WORLD.
JUST AS ZELENSKYY IS DEDICATED
TO THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE FIRST,
BIDEN NEEDS TO BE COMMITTED TO
THE AMERICAN IDEAL AND THAT'S
WHAT HE'S DOING PROMOTING PEACE
HOPEFULLY AND WORKING FOR THAT
PIECE AND MULTIPLE WAYS.
I THINK WE NEED SOME CLARITY.
MOST AMERICANS DON'T REALIZE
THAT ZELENSKYY WAS COMEDIAN AND
ACTOR WHO STARTED IN A SHOW
CALLED SERVANT OF THE PEOPLE
ABOUT A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER WHO
FOUND HIMSELF PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE WITH THE ACTOR
EVENTUALLY BECAME HE NAMED HIS
POLITICAL PARTY, SERVANT OF THE
PEOPLE.
THIS IS AN AMAZING EXAMPLE OF
LIFE.
>> ALL OF OUR COUNTRY, WE HAVE
BEEN WAITING FOR THIS FOR SO
MUCH TIME.
>> UKRAINIAN UKRAINIANS?
>> YES, UKRAINIAN SPIRIT
>> IN SOME WAYS, THE WHOLE STOR
IS RIGHT THERE.
THE U.S. AND EUROPE MADE
OVERTURES, HOOTON FELT
THREATENED AND ZELENSKYY BECAME
THE LASSO OF THE WORLD LEADERS.
>> MEANWHILE, BIDEN, HE IS
LOOKING MORE LIKE ANTHONY
HOPKINS IN THE FATHER.
WHAT WAS THIS, YESTERDAY?
>> S, THIS IS YESTERDAY.
>> WE HAD A DIFFERENT
ARRANGEMENT OF HIS ON THE STAGE
BECAUSE OF THE FIRST LADIES HAS
BEEN CONTRACTING COVID.
PARDON?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, SHE'S FINE.
IT'S ME.
THAT'S NOT TOGETHER.
SECONDLY, FIRST GENTLEMAN.
HOW ABOUT THAT.
>> LAURA, SO HE HAD COVID COME
OF THE PRESIDENT, DUG HIM OFF I
THE SECOND LADY, HE'S NOT SURE
OF ANYTHING AND I REALLY WORRY
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT GOING TO
EUROPE.
THERE IS BREAKING NEWS TONIGHT
THAT YOU RAN NEW DEAL, HE SAYS
ONE THING HOOTON IS A WAR
CRIMINAL, HERE'S WHAT THEY'RE
DOING ON THE POLICY FRONT, IN
THAT HE RAN NUKE DEAL, GUESS WH
GETS THE $10 BILLION CONTRACT
AND ALL SANCTIONS WAIVED TO
BUILD THE IRANI AND NUCLEAR
PLANTS?
RUSSIA.
ITS IN THE IRAN NUKE DEAL, IT I
MIND BLOWING WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THIS ADMINISTRATION BETTER GET
IT STORY TOGETHER WITH ITS
POLICY.
RIGHT NOW THEY ARE AT ODDS PART.
>> I TAKE ISSUE WITH THIS IDEA
THAT BIDEN IS PURSUING PIECE.
I THINK HE SEES--HE SEES WHAT
OBAMA SOUGHT IN SYRIA WHICH IS
WHY HE STEPPED BACK FROM THE
REDLINE.
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE JOINED BECAUS
HE REALIZED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DON'T WANT THIS.
OBAMA STEP BACK AND NOW BIDEN I
KIND OF DOING THAT SAME THING.
ENO'S THAT IT'S TOO RISKY TO GE
INVOLVED IN SOME PROTRACTED
MILITARY ADVENTURE.
>> HE IS THROWING BILLIONS AT
THIS THING.
I APPLAUD HIS RESTRAINTS, MANY
PEOPLE ARE TELLING THEM TO SIN
PLANES, WE HAVE TO DO MORE,
ZELENSKYY IS DOING THE PUSH.
HE STICKS TO THE PLAN, BUT THIS
IRAN NUKE DEAL CONTRADICTS
EVERYTHING YOU SEE.
ONE GOOD NEWS ON THE UKRAINE
FRONT.
POPE FRANCIS HAD A VIDEO CALL
WHO SUPPORTED THE HOOTON
INVASION.
THE POPE TOLD HIM TODAY THE WAR
IS ALWAYS UNJUST AND THEY AS
RELIGIOUS LEADERS HAVE TO USE
THE OF JESUS.
HE'S ALSO HAVING A VERY
CONSECRATION CONSECRATING THE
COUNTRY OF RUSSIA.
>> BELIEVE THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT RAYMOND ARROYO HAS
SAID SOMETHING TRULY, COMPLETEL
POSITIVE ABOUT POPE FRANCIS.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
FINALLY, IF ZELENSKYY WAS
LOOKING FOR A CITIZEN OF THE
WORLD LEADER HE SHOULD'VE TURNE
ON NETFLIX.
ROCK OBAMA IS HOSTING A NEW
DOCUMENTARY CALLED OUR NATIONAL
PARKS.
GLOBAL NATIONAL PARKS.
>> JOINED JOIN IN THE
CELEBRATION OF OUR PLANET
GREATEST NATIONAL PARKS AND
WILDERNESS.
>> THEY JOURNEY THROUGH THE
NATURAL WONDERS OF OUR SHARED
BIRTHRIGHT.
>> ALONG WITH THE $1 BILLION OF
ARMAMENTS, I HOPE OBAMA SINCE
THE SLEEPY'S LOSS TO UKRAINE.
THEY COULD USE THE HELP OF.
>> THE SLEEPY'S LOFT, WAS THAT
IT DID GET BIDEN?
>> NO, IT'S SLEEPY SLOTH.
>> HE'S MOVING PARK SPREAD.
>> HEAT AND MICHELLE GOT LIKE
125 MILLION AND THEIR NETFLIX
DEAL.
IT LOOKED LIKE HE WAS IN HAWAII
WITH THAT GREEN SCREEN BACK.
IT LOOKS LIKE A NICE SHOW.